good evening everyone
thank you very much for coming before we
attempt to answer anything let's pray
and ask god for wisdom
our loving father in heaven we come to
you as your children at your invitation
we need insight lord to answer this
question granted to us i pray
in jesus name amen
okay the first question and the only
question for this
tonight is pastor skeet is it possible
to live without sinning
that's a very profound question the
simple answer is yes
it's not only is it possible is it
required
and the answer is yes now can you do it
in your own strength the answer is a
resounding thunderous no
why did jesus come to show us what is
possible in human flesh
that holds on to divine power let me say
that again
jesus demonstrated in his life what is
possible in the life of a human being
when that person lays hold on and
refuses to let go divine power
when jacob wrestled with the angel the
angel said let me go that was christ
and jacob said no not except you blessed
me
and because he overcame the bible says
he overcame with men and with god
it is possible by holding on to god
to live one day at a time
without sinning let me ask you this and
i shall release you dr ellie
the next surgeon general of the united
states dr ellie kim
let me ask you this is it possible to
live one day without sinning yes or no
yes if it is possible to do it for one
day
it is possible to do it from now until
god puts you in the grave if he chooses
to do that before he comes
because we are required to live what
kind of lives
one day at a time
now you may find that funny when god
sent manna
exodus 16 how much did how much mana did
he send for monday
only enough for monday how much did he
send for wednesday
only enough for wednesday that's god's
lesson
live one day at a time now if you ask me
after smoking for 25 years can you give
up smoking for another
for 50 years i may say no are you crazy
but if you ask me can i give it up for
one day
yes christians live too much for the
future
we must live for today and if we
live for today if we use the manna
god gives us for today and that's all he
promises
today we will live victorious
christian lives somebody say amen
the answer is yes we it not only can we
live above sin by the power of christ
we are required to live above sin